antenne de 20 heures le journal de la
rédaction Henri Sannier
bonsoir et bienvenue sur le plateau
d'Antenne 2 à la une ce soir la reprise
sur les marchés financiers plus 8,3% à
la Bourse de Paris Wall Street également
à la hausse depuis quelques minutes la
réduction du déficit du commerce
extérieur américain redonne
incontestablement le moral au boursier
voilà pour les titres
ouverture du 50e sommet franco-allemand
à karlsruh au programme coopération en
matière de défense d'agriculture et bien
sûr les problèmes monétaires en pleine
tourmente financière mondiale
la phase finale des états généraux de la
sécurité sociale mille personnalités
réunies à Paris pour une première
journée de débat animé
de rugbymen roumain choisissent de
rester en France à l'issue de leur match
d'hier contre les Tricolores ils ont
tout de reçu dans la journée une
autorisation provisoire de séjour
Jean-Paul Kaufmann
Jean-Louis Normandin d'Antenne 2 et
Roger hahaha les otages français au
Liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés
400 mutins dans la cour de la prison de
Saint-Maur dans le département de
l'Indre la mutinerie a débuté cet
après-midi vers 17h le directeur est au
moins 10 personnes seraient prises en
otage la prison aurait été saccagée
c'est tout ce que l'on sait pour le
moment toutes les forces de police et de
gendarmerie de Châteauroux et des
environs se sont rendus sur les lieux on
attend maintenant l'arrivée du GIGN je
vous propose d'écouter le témoignage
d'une personne qui habite juste en face
de la prison Thierry Calmette vient de
la joindre au téléphone écoutez
à l'intérieur de la centrale il y a ils
ont mis le feu
au niveau des cuisines et des cellules
qu'est-ce que vous voyez de chez vous
une fumée
qui vient de nombre de l'incendie et
sinon on voit rien parce que je veux
dire il y a toutes les barrages de
gendarmes etc donc et puis on essaye pas
trop sortir
la gendarmerie vous a donné quelques
recommandations oui de pas rester de ne
pas sortir de rentrer et de fermer les
fenêtres et voler etc c'est pas bouger
voilà monsieur pendreau vient d'arriver
à Châteauroux à la centrale de
Saint-Maur je viens de la prendre nous
essaierons d'appeler Châteauroux en
direct dans quelques minutes plus 0,2%
c'est la hausse des prix pour le mois
d'octobre un bon chiffre et un motif de
réconfort dans la grisaille monétaire et
boursière c'est le premier commentaire
du ministère de l'économie et des
finances en un an la hausse des prix
s'élève à 3,1% à noter qu'en octobre
nous réalisons le même chiffre que les
Allemands ce qui est en soit une
référence regarde l'optimisme également
à la Bourse de Paris ou les valeurs
françaises ont affiché aujourd'hui une
hausse de
8,3%, la reprise du dollar est surtout
impossible accord entre la Maison
Blanche et le Congrès explique en partie
cette évolution mais aujourd'hui on
attendait surtout les chiffres du
commerce extérieur américain se sont eux
souvenez-vous qui le mois dernier avait
précipité les marchés boursiers dans la
tourmente les chiffres s'améliorent sont
un peu meilleur et les experts poussent
ce soir un grand ouf de soulagement là
aussi nous y reviendrons
à part cela à part cela et nous allons
tout de suite le découvrir avant même de
connaître les chiffres Edouard Balladur
avait annoncé ce matin le report de la
privatisation du AP compte tenu de la
situation sur les marchés boursiers a
dit le ministre laissons passer les
fêtes de fin d'année on verra après sur
le problème de fonds Edouard Balladur et
formel pas de changement de cap mais
inquiétude pour la croissance
écoutons-le je crois que lorsque l'on
peut dire tout d'abord c'est que la
crise que ville monte crise monétaire et
crise boursière il faut que nous les
dominions très vite grâce à une
coopération accrue entre les grands pays
industrialisés
et il faut dire en second lieu que nous
pouvons nous ne savons pas encore
quelles vont être les résultats de ces
de cette crise mais nous pouvons
parfaitement surmonter les difficultés
qui en résulteront si la coopération est
que monnaie européenne se renforce et si
nous sommes capables de maintenir la
croissance en Europe cela est encore
trop tôt pour le savoir mais tous nos
efforts vont dans ce pus monsieur
Balladur apparemment maintient le cap
Philippe Sassier mais ce qu'il a
toujours les coudées aussi franches
qu'il y a quelques semaines et quelques
mois ecoutez il y a deux bonnes
nouvelles qui sont venu mettre du baume
au cœur d'Edouard Balladur aujourd'hui
d'abord c'est un bon indice des prix qui
permet de la différence d'inflation
entre la France et l'Allemagne de se
réduire et l'État sont plus bas niveau
cette différence depuis 14 ans ensuite
une bonne nouvelle une entreprise va
braver la tempête boursière il s'agit
des petits sucs carolls des poules verts
pendant Carole qui ont quand même
s'introduire en Bourse lundi mais le
ministre à d'autres soucis qui sont les
répercussions de sur la vie économique
de l'État et des Français du séisme
financier il y a secouer le monde il a
reconnu que la croissance 88 ne sera
peut-être pas aussi forte que la
prévision officielle qui est de 2,2%. le
gouvernement affirme qu'il n'est pas
question de changer de politique mais
plusieurs experts estiment que l'an
prochain il y aura moins de croissance
mais aussi peut-être moins
d'investissement et de consommation pour
le budget pour le budget de l'État une
croissance plus faible signifie moins de
rentrer fiscale et si les privatisations
ne repartaient pas cela signifierait des
pertes de recettes à ces importantes
pour l'État certains députés de la
majorité se demandent s'il ne faudrait
pas discuter plusieurs aspects du budget
88 avant de le voter c'est ce que pense
quelques baristes notamment la tornade
boursière pourrait donc rallumer
certains débats économiques non
seulement entre le gouvernement et
l'opposition mais aussi au sein de la
majorité merci Philippe à l'Assemblée le
Front national revient à la charge en
prenant la partie une nouvelle fois
Rachid arabe journaliste dans la
rédaction d'Antenne 2 rappelons que le
confrères et de nationalité algériennes
un député du Front national a dénigrer à
Rachid Arab le droit de commenter la
politique intérieure française cette
fois la classe politique réagit encore
plus durement que d'habitude très
vigoureusement a commencé par le
ministre de la Communication François
Léotard
il faut que les Français le sachent nous
entendons des choses inadmissibles à
l'Assemblée nationale et notamment de ce
parlementaire appartenant au Front
National qui dit des choses incroyables
sur un journaliste il faut bien dire que
ça ça n'est pas la France ça ça n'est
pas le Parlement ça ça ne s'appelle pas
la liberté et je n'accepterai pas un
pays et que dans un pays comme le nôtre
on puisse faire en sorte que des
journalistes se sentent ou humiliés ou
menacés ou tout simplement handicapés
dans leur libre expression est-ce qu'au
nom du gouvernement vous seriez prêt à
demander une sanction envers les députés
du Front national si de telle pratique
se poursuivait à l'Assemblée je souhaite
que ce soit sovielle et ça viendra vous
le verrez surtout de du Parlement
lui-même le gouvernement quand il est au
Parlement n'est pas chez lui c'est aussi
une règle très importante et je respecte
profondément les procédures internes qui
sont celles du Parlement mais j'ai un
certain nombre d'amis au Parlement et je
peux vous dire que je me rapprocherai
d'eux pour faire en sorte qu'on ne
laisse pas dire un certain nombre de
choses comme celles qui sont exprimées
aujourd'hui il y va d'ailleurs de
l'honneur du Parlement français et de
l'ensemble des parlementaires français
autre réaction celle du Parti socialiste
au nom du péage Jean-Jacques Keran vient
de déclarer je cite ses propos il faut
dénoncer avec la plus grande vigueur de
telle propos qui mettent en cause la
liberté de l'information mais aussi la
dignité d'un homme ces propos sont une
insulte au droit de l'homme fin de
citation l'avenir de la sécurité sociale
je vous rappelle que les spécialistes
prévoient un déficit record de 30
milliards en 1988 pour faire face le
gouvernement a lancé une vaste
consultation vous connaissez le slogan
ne tombons pas une grande idée la
baleine qu'il faut sauver c'est le
symbole des états généraux de la
sécurité sociale aujourd'hui et demain
les États généraux se terminent par un
grand show ce show débouchera-t-il sur
des propositions concrètes si oui
seront-elles prises en considération par
le gouvernement voyons cela avec
Véronique Augé
pendant une heure nous avons failli voir
naître de véritables consensus et puis
tout à capoter un exemple l'augmentation
des taxes sur les tabacs et alcool
prenez par le rapport des sages toutes
les parties prenantes semblaient
d'accord jusqu'au moment où Paul
Marcellin de la CGC s'est mis à hurler
que tout cela ne tournait par rond
comment dit-il l'État peut-il demander
au contribuable de subventionner les
viticulteurs et en même temps décourager
leurs clients de boire du vin il faut le
reconnaître les participants des États
généraux ont perdu leur langue de bois
et les débats ont parfois chauffés mais
la journée a suffi pour démontrer
l'éloignement des parties prenantes sur
l'ensemble des sujets brûlants au point
que Jean-Pierre et cabach le meneur des
débats s'était crié est-ce que dans 10
ans on aura encore la même discussion en
France c'est Jacques beau-père le
président des syndicats de médecins qui
a donné la raison de se fouillis
l'absence de volonté bien définie du
gouvernement en matière de sécurité
sociale qu'il établisse les règles du
jeu et qui nous laisse travailler à
déclarer Jacques beau-père un appel
destiné à Philippe Seguin le ministre
des Affaires sociales
forte participation vous l'avez vu des
organisations professionnelles et
syndicales tout le monde était là y
compris les représentants de la CGT mais
Henri krazuki le leader du syndicat
avait préféré prendre un peu de recul au
cours d'une manifestation qui rassemblée
plusieurs milliers de personnes à Paris
en rétrazuki à notamment déclaré que le
système de protection de la sécurité
sociale méritait autre chose qu'une
opération médiatique grosse comme une
baleine je cite ses propos à carlsruh en
Allemagne 50e sommet franco-allemand un
sommet dominé par les problèmes de
défense dans le communiqué final il
devrait être question de la brigade
intégrée franco-allemande dont on parle
beaucoup et de la coopération européenne
en matière de sécurité à noter que les
Allemands devraient se prononcer une
nouvelle fois sur la réduction des
arsenaux nucléaires à courte portée dans
un autre répertoire et en dehors des
manifestations officielles le sommet
franco-allemand débouche sur un accord
plutôt inattendu l'administration ouest
allemand va donner son feu vert au
Minitel français le militaire en
Allemagne
c'est la mort d'une coopération
européenne sans précédent en matière de
communication
à cela les Allemands ne pourront pas y
jouer sérieux la corne concerne que les
usages professionnels du Minitel
pourtant cette machine les allemands
n'en voulaient pas il a fallu trois ans
d'apprent négociation et de menaces de
procès pour protectionnisme mal placé
pour qu'enfin la poste allemande la
Bundespost accepte d'ouvrir ses lignes
au terminaux fabriquées par télé mais
pour l'instant il ne s'agit que d'un
agrément tout reste à faire en
particulier pour que le Minitel présente
de l'intérêt il faut qu'il soit relié à
des centres serveurs et ce sera aux
Français de les créer au mieux donc les
ventes ne débuteront que d'ici 4 à 5 ans
la RFA est le 22e pays homologué le
Minitel mais les exportations sont
encore très faibles par exemple 10 000
appareils par mois vers les États-Unis
c'est encore très peu comparé aux 4000
installés chaque jour en France où ce
clavier son écran sont devenus un
véritable phénomène de société et cela
c'est le plus difficile à exporter dans
l'affaire lucer la Cour de cassation a
désigné cet après-midi une juridiction
spéciale afin d'entendre deux personnes
mises en cause directement dans
l'affaire des ventes d'armes à l'Iran
ces deux personnes sont Jean-François
Dubeau ancien conseiller technique de
Charlène nu et François Bernard son
ancien chef de cabinet cette décision
pourrait marquer le véritable démarrage
de cette affaire au niveau juridique
Hervé Brusini
un magistrat parisien bientôt désigné
dans le dossier luchères très
certainement le juge le grand dans son
cabinet les hommes de l'affaire vont
avoir à s'expliquer témoin numéro 1
Daniel de Wavrin le PDG de la société
soupçonné d'avoir livré les 450 000 obus
à l'Iran c'est l'homme clé du dossier si
face au magistrats il confirme ses
précédentes déclarations faites au
contrôleur général des armées Barba
l'instruction peut progressera pas de
géant et les inculpations se multiplient
pour le juge Legrand il va s'agir de
situer exactement
celle des membres du cabinet du
ministère de la Défense de l'époque à
commencer par Jean-François Dubosc
souvent décrit comme l'homme fort du
ministère Jean-François Dubosc l'une des
cibles privilégiées du rapport Barba si
haut fonctionnaires risquent d'être
inculpé d'infraction à la législation
sur les armes et puis le juge devra
examiner une à une les étapes qui ont
conduit à la décision de cette vente
d'armée légale les organismes les hommes
ainsi par exemple à la Délégation
générale à l'armement l'ingénieur
général Émile blanc lui aussi citée par
le rapport Barba et comme lui d'autres
ingénieurs généraux des militaires de
Oran comme le général Vautrin décidément
beaucoup de monde risque de défiler dans
le bureau du juge le grand pourtant il
manque encore une pièce au dossier une
pièce qui peut être essentielle dans ce
travail d'instruction et 14 rapports
établis par l'ancienne sécurité
militaire elle avait à l'époque alerté
les autorités des imprudences commises
par une société appelée luchères Henry
merci voyons rapidement les autres
télégrammes de l'actualité plein feu sur
la Chine avant le quatrième volet de
notre enquête on se retrouve dans
quelques instants
ingénieur français blessé dans le
secteur chrétien de Beyrouth est
toujours dans le coma Richard jimpel a
été agressé hier sur une autoroute par
trois hommes armées mon mari ne se
connaissait pas d'ennemis a déclaré son
épouse d'origine libanaise la France
condamne cet attentat qui n'a toujours
pas été revendiqué
la Croix-Rouge médiateur après
l'enlèvement des huit passagers du Silco
nous cherchons rencontrer abounida la
déclarée aujourd'hui le responsable de
la Croix Rouge au Liban une rencontre
officieuse a eu lieu à Beyrouth avec le
Fatar révolutionnaire c'est lui qui
retiendrait les otages capturés dimanche
au large d'Israël
l'opéra de Francfort ravagé par un
incendie criminel la nuit dernière pas
de victimes mais des dégâts importants
le toit du bâtiment s'est effondré il y
aurait 430 millions de francs de
dommages le pyromane est sous les
verrous on ne connaît ni son identité ni
les motifs de son acte
le président chinois monsieur Lixian nan
on commence à bien le connaître poursuit
son voyage officiel à Paris on l'a vu
flâner aujourd'hui au musée du Louvre
pendant qu'à Pékin le Parlement se
réunissait pour désigner un nouveau
Premier ministre si les pronostics sont
respectés monsieur lipeng 59 ans
succédera à Monsieur zaozybang devenu
numéro 1 du régime on murmure que les
nouveaux dirigeants plutôt
pro-soviétiques aurait l'intention de
freiner la politique des réformes
économiques et surtout la trop grande
ouverture de la Chine sur l'étranger il
est vrai que depuis quelques années les
Chinois ont découvert tour à tour les
marchés libres les marchés noirs et
quelques combines reportages Alain et
roux et Claudio
en Chine populaire la moto est un signe
extérieur de richesse
on dit même que les jeunes filles à
marier ne sont pas insensibles à cet
argument
chaque jour les motards se rassemblent
en banlieue pour vendre acheter et
surtout frimer
et 30000 la municipalité de pékin vient
de suspendre les nouvelles
immatriculations des deux roues
officiellement pour prévenir les
accidents une seule solution acheter
d'occasion
la mienne je vais payer 6000 francs et
moi 5000 francs
et vous combien de temps il vous a fallu
deux ans deux ans
ce sont des fils de cadre des marchands
de moutons des restaurateurs en marge du
cadre collectiviste qui peuvent se payer
une moto ou bien ce blouson qui coûte
400 francs
un marché très libre mais restreint qui
se situe à la limite de la légalité plus
proche pour les autorités du libéralisme
bourgeois que du système socialiste dont
la bicyclette à 400 francs reste le
symbole
à propos de la Chine je signale que nos
confrères du magazine elle lance un
premier numéro en chinois mais oui dans
un premier temps le magazine ne sera
vendu à Hong Kong mais tous les sapés
que nos confrères n'en resteront pas là
au hasard des dépêches et des
déclarations nous jonglons vous le savez
quotidiennement avec les chiffres de
l'actualité j'avoue que l'exercice
devient presque banal il n'empêche que
parfois on attrape le vertige ce matin
par exemple on apprenait que les iris le
célèbre tableau de Van Gogh venait
d'être vendu près de 54 millions de
dollars à New York 54 millions de
dollars soit la bagatelle de 30
milliards de centimes l'art serait-il
devenu la valeur refuge en période de
troubles financiers on est tenté de le
croire Patrice Pelé
qui a dit que les fleurs sont
périssables en tout cas celles devant
Gogh ont bien tenu le coup 49 millions
de dollars près de 320 millions de
francs celui qui a acheté la toile ne
s'est pas fait connaître le marché de
l'art semble ne plus avoir de limites
lors la bourse l'immobilier sont balayé
ceux qui ont de l'argent se dirigent
vers les salles de vente 50 millions de
dollars est un prix exceptionnel pour
une toile exceptionnelle hors du commun
dans des conditions aussi
exceptionnelles il faut savoir
aujourd'hui ce qu'est la crise
économique mondiale et il y a là
probablement aussi une valeur refuge en
ce qui concerne Van Gogh il y a deux
facteurs très importants la rareté de
l'oeuvre l'exceptionnel qualité de
l'oeuvre et maintenant le marché
financier qui fait que on ne sait plus
que 20 dollar l'art va le refuge
attention certains redoutent que ce
marché ne s'effondre à son tour la bonne
affaire d'aujourd'hui pourrait ne plus
l'être demain Van Gogh mieux que
personne aurait pu en parler il est mort
seul et pauvre à l'âge de 37 ans
le sport Jeannie Longo se défend c'était
ce matin chez elle à Grenoble accusé de
dopage par les Américains la triple
championne du monde crie haut et fort je
suis une athlète intègre et saine
Dominique Le glou
voici une produit utilisé par Jeannie
Longo et incriminé il s'appelle exosulyn
c'est un produit de phytothérapie il
contient de l'effet draps une plante
japonaise qui produit de l'effet drin
une substance que l'on retrouve dans
tous ces produits de beauté ou de soins
tous ces produits seraient donc de pans
au terme de la loi en tant qu'athlète
intègre et scène je n'ai absolument pas
voulu toucher aux produits interdits
en tant que femme également je connais
quelques problèmes circulatoires de
jambes lourdes propres à toutes les
femmes et j'ai donc eu recours à la
phytothérapie notamment un produit nommé
exosuline cela en période d'entraînement
ce produit est en vente libre et ne
figure pas sur la liste des produits
interdits une affaire qui rappelle celle
d'Alexis Grewal peu avant les Jeux de
Los Angeles s'il était reconnu coupable
d'avoir absorbé de l'effet de rime lui
c'était pour soigner une crise d'asthme
après examen la commission américaine
annule sa décision des jours plus tard
greywald devenaient le premier Américain
champion olympique sur route
rugby défections roumaine au lendemain
du match France - Roumanie match
international un match gagné haut la
main vous le savez par les Français 49-3
deux joueurs Roumains ont faussé
compagnie à leurs équipes aux dernières
nouvelles ils ont demandé une
autorisation provisoire de séjour Jean
ma mère
laurensu Constantine et sans conteste le
plus célèbre il est deuxième ligne de
l'équipe nationale depuis plusieurs
années et a joué la Coupe du Monde
âgé de 24 ans perdent un petit garçon de
2 mois il a tout quitté après avoir
mûrement pensé sa décision il s'est
refusé à toute déclaration après avoir
demandé et obtenu une autorisation
provisoire de séjour premier et
principal problème à résoudre pour lui
celui de sa situation matérielle quant à
Victor Abraham l'autre réfugié il est
resté tout simplement âge chez
l'interprète roumain moins de problèmes
familiaux pour lui mais un choix
délibéré la saisie d'une chance pour un
passage en France
des motifs très politiques
en attendant de demander sans doute
l'asile politique il aimerait rester à
jeun une affaire qui est embarrasse bien
le président férase mais pour qui ce
n'est qu'une question de politique on
enchaîne avec la voile voici tout de
suite des nouvelles de la Mini Transat
le vainqueur s'appelle Laurent Bourgnon
il vient d'arriver à Pointe-à-Pitre il y
a quelques heures un véritable exploit
car son bateau ne fait pas plus de 6
mètres voyons tout de suite les images
cet acrobate escaladant son main pour y
réparer la girouette déficience c'est
Laurent Bourgnon le vainqueur de cette
deuxième étape de la Mini Transat il
possédait pour cela il est vrai le
bateau Haddock pour remporter la
victoire totale il ne faut pas que son
poursuivant immédiat Gilles charrie
franchise la ligne d'arrivée avant
minuit ce soir après plus de 25 jours de
navigation solitaire sur son petit
bateau nourrit seulement à base de
ration de survie Laurent Bourgnon est
arrivé en pleine forme et la tête pleine
de souvenirs comme il l'a expliqué à
Gérard Holtz en nuit pleine lune avec
plein de dauphins partout et bateaux
marcher super vite avec un bord de l'arc
serré et c'était merveilleux tous les
dauphins et de l'eau fluorescente ça
c'est les souvenirs c'est ça reste tout
le temps et l'arrivée à la Martinique en
premier en temps réel ça fait plaisir
aussi
regardez bien sur le petit écran voici
la tradition qui veut ça les résultats
du quarté d'Auteuil il fallait jouer cet
après-midi le 1 le 5 le 2 et le 9 dans
l'ordre
2769 francs 50 dans un ordre différent
172 francs tout cela pour 5 francs bien
sûr la météo la météo synonyme de
tempête Sophie surtout dans l'Ouest et
bien oui Henri les ventes sont encore
déchaînés l'année dernière sur l'ouest
du que vous allez voir des images le
Cotentin en proie des rafales de 110
km/h les plus diluviennes se sont
abattus sur la région de La Hague
provoquant de graves inondations le
bilan est déjà lourd 150 maisons ont été
inondées une personne âgée s'est noyée
dans sa cave le département de la Manche
a été déclaré sinistré après le passage
de cette tempête pour demain et bien non
la météo nationale est pessimiste pour
demain des vents devront encore nous
empoisonner de la Vendée aux côtes de la
Manche en soufflant par rafale de 130
km/h sur les côtes 90 km/h à l'intérieur
du pays alors c'est vendre reine n'avait
que des nuages et de la pluie 80% de
chances de pluie sur l'Aquitaine sur le
Massif Central la Franche-Comté et
l'Alsace sur la Corse encore quelques
risques d'averses demain alternance
d'averses d'éclaircit et devant donc
très fort sur tout l'ouest du pays les
Charentes la Bretagne et côte de la
Manche ainsi que le Bassin parisien et
puis tout de même quelques éclaircies
sur le littoral méditerranéen ou le ciel
sera dégagé par du Mistral les
températures en revanche restent douce
et c'est une bonne nouvelle elle sèche
le rond de degré à Lille et à Cherbourg
jusqu'à 14 degrés à Nantes et de 12
degrés à Limoges jusqu'à 20 degrés 20
degrés pardon à Bastia voilà demain il y
aura trois minutes de soleil en moins
nous fêterons les Brice et attention
Henri ce sera un vendredi 13
non ça dépend on termine en musique
France Gall fait sa rentrée au zénith ce
soir à Paris c'est un événement car
France Gall quelques années après et
toujours en tête des hit parade France
Gall au Zénith en avant-première pour
Antenne 2
et là elle a elle l'a le talent elle l'a
fait gueral bien sûr une des chansons
phares du nouveau spectacle France Gall
bichonné au bémol près par Michel Berger
le complice depuis la déclaration
d'amour 13 musicos niveau mondial cuivre
US tambour africain guitare supergratte
avec ça elle débranche pas la France
elle assume
23 ans de carrière côté fan plus de baba
cool mais de toute jeunes filles
c'est mon ami c'est une personne qui
boit qui mange qui pleure qui rit mais
moi je trouve ça plutôt ça
parce que on peut pas être fan toute sa
vie de quelqu'un ça c'est bizarre c'est
embêtant ça veut dire tu es une star
c'est vrai et dans le vrai sens du terme
mais ça fait toujours rire moi quand les
autres
c'est pas des filles ça charme
cette petite flammes
tarte les tonneaux sont des pianos
surtout ce que peut se mettre entre les
mains on peut se prendre un petit peu
pour Dieu par moment alors donc c'est
pas mal d'arrêter et d'aller faire son
marché de d'emmener les enfants à
l'école
et là c'est vrai que c'est une chanson
qui porte un disque qui tire un disque
parce qu'une chanson qui est évidente et
je veux dire à l'écoute c'est vrai elle
est forte elle est évidente Cézanne
c'est autre chose c'est ce qu'on appelle
une chanson d'album
perdue au fond d'un album mais cette
chanson là m'a apporté plus que
n'importe quel autre parce qu'elle a
fait que des gens qui s'intéressaient
pas à moi se sont arrêtés sur moi se
sont attachés à ce que je faisais
chanson paysage une des plus belles
réussites du couple France Gall Michel
Berger deux talents complémentaires le
résultat est là et l'étoile de la star
est au zénith
voilà je vous rappelle la principale
information du journal celle que je vous
donnais tout à l'heure en ouverture à
20h 400 mutins sont dans la cour de la
prison Saint-Maur de la prison de
Châteauroux dans l'Indre depuis cet
après-midi le directeur est au moins 10
personnes ont été prises en otage selon
nos dernières informations des
informations que nous venons d'avoir au
téléphone plusieurs bâtiments de la
prison était incendiés tandis que les
mutins essaient peu à peu de d'investir
tous les locaux de la centrale en se
dirigeant vers la porte une porte qui
avait été détruit je vous le rappelle il
y a deux jours au cours de l'évasion de
Jacques hiver autre précision importante
je vous rappelle que la prison de
Saint-Maur dans le département de
l'Indre abrite 400 détenus parmi
lesquels George Ibrahim Abdallah
prochain rendez-vous d'information 22h20
résistance présentée par Noël Mamère
plaidoyer pour les femmes le magazine a
été enregistré entièrement au Bangladesh
à 23h30 le journal sera présenté par
obriger excellente soirée sur Antenne 2
je vous retrouve demain 20h bonsoir